this video will end with our ascension
of ashina castle
but our story begins many years before
that it begins before wolfe was assigned
to be
the divine princess shinobi before he
was plucked from the battlefield
by his father we have to go back even
before ishin ashuna founded this nation
all the way back to a people who loved
the ancient land
they lived upon before this land was
the place where we the ashina people
lived
where the waters flowed straight from
the source
we were a people who loved our country
dearly
but we were heretics and we were weak
naturally we were overrun trampled
into submission for many long
excruciating
years we couldn't even pray at the water
from the springs
the way we were then but then the world
fell into chaos
could you tell me about the rebellion
we just took back what was stolen from
us
amidst the chaos that was japan
the endless casualties the flames of war
we found the perfect opportunity to take
back our land
a sword saint of the ashina turned the
tide in the rebellion
a devil with the sword his technique was
eagerly polished in the blood of his
enemies
and his single-minded search for
strength
ended with him securing ashna's
independence once more
pivotal initian's coup were his seven
spears
of whom very few remain in game and of
course his generals
every one of them accomplished in the
now famous
ashina sword style and in the aftermath
of the rebellion
an hour plucks a starving wolf from the
battlefield
well would you look at that fascinating
will you join me starving wolf our
hunger may beget
a fine shinobi making us a worthy right
hand
someone utterly loyal to our foster
father
and to this end we are eventually
assigned a prestigious role
shinobi tokuro a young child who is an
heir
to a divine bloodline as your father
my word is absolute your masters is a
close
second it's possible that this scene
where we're tasked with the divine air's
protection takes place
in the harata estates this is an
abundant tract of land
that was likely owned by kuro's uncle
who
would likely have taken him in after the
death of his mother
and father and uncle we never meet
for everyone around the divine heir
seems to die
i tried my best to be his guardian but
look at me now three years before the
start of the game
the harada are raided by a swarm of
bandits they all
attack with perfect timing when all of
the young soldiers are out fighting
likely on behalf of the ashina in their
war
so only the older warriors remain here
to
protect the divine air hear me
my name is
i stood with the ashina when they
claimed this land
the harata are a cadet branch of the
ashana
they share a really long history with
the clan
and here three years before the events
of the main game
that long history ends and you were not
by your prince's side
you you're the young master shinobi
what good are you you were nowhere to be
seen when things went south
protecting kuro is your second rule but
your first loyalty is to your father
so it follows that your father must have
sent you away from harata
in order for the attack to succeed after
all
this banded attack was his idea taking
the hirata estate was surprisingly easy
owl's info was right on the money you
know the man
drizzle is talking to is masanari a lone
shadow of the interior ministry
and you can think of the interior
ministry as a sort of central government
force
in japan it's a force that appears to
have come out on top
of japan's sengoku era conflict and
now they have the ashina clan on their
hit list the bandits are simply a means
to an end
they're a way for the interior ministry
to strike a blow against the ashina
and mask the interior ministry's
involvement he's a villain
a downran out villain masonry well
he's useful right now so endure him for
all his scheming he's a nameless
rogue shinobi his efforts won't amount
to much
father ah it's you
i'm afraid i made a bit of a blunder
perhaps the years have finally caught up
with me
ah protect your master
with your life
al fakes his death now able to operate
fully in the shadows while you build a
stronger connection
with the divine air by rescuing him from
this nightmare
my lord
it's been a long time
is phantom butterfly a master of
illusions who
trained you in the shinobi arts at al's
request
al's real name is usui and lady
butterfly herself
trained in usual's forest a place far to
the north filled with
mist and mystifications she trained you
since you were a cub and with her dying
breath
she finally acknowledges your growth
ladybutterfly
forgive me you've
gotten stronger
wolf al's ultimate goal
is immortality the power of the dragon's
heritage
it's a power held by kuro that can be
transferred to another
kuro has lost his mother he's lost his
father his uncle his clan
and now he's lost his shinobi
as well who just so happens to be al's
loyal cub
you fought bravely on my behalf
i cannot throw away such loyalty
loyal wolf take my blood and live
again
it's my theory that al clears out the
harata estates and
might have even killed kudos mother and
father in order to increase
kudos reliance on us and by extension
al as well an indeterminable amount of
time
passes and you awaken in a well deep
within ashina lands
wounded and with little memory of recent
events
a single sakura petal falls from our
person
representing a rebirth that we must have
experienced here
this is the power of the dragon's
heritage a power that al
lady butterfly and now lord genichiro
crave for their own ends imprisoning a
mere child
i feel sorry for the boy agreed that i'm
sure lord ganichiro has his reasons
lord ganichiro now leads the ashina clan
in his grandfather's stead
for ishin is old ailing but apparently
he's
not too keen to keep a child locked up
there's a secret passage beneath the
moat bridge that will take us out of the
castle
lord ishin told me about it once so with
our sword kusabi maru
and elum of the harata family and kuro
one of their last living members by our
side we attempt to flee ashina
and abandon all allegiance to this
country but it was not to be
the divine heir last we stood together
was your uncle's funeral
as mentioned earlier kudos uncle was of
the herata
a man who took him in after the death of
his parents
by mentioning their shared presence at
the funeral kenichiro is reminding kudo
of his blood ties to the ashina
and shaming him for the fealty to
country and kin that he is shirking to
genichiro
that fealty is everything for kenichiro
was actually born a peasant
taken in by the ashina after his
mother's death
there is an astounding amount of parent
child complexes in sakura and it
wouldn't surprise me if kenichiro
thought of this country as a substitute
for his own mother
in a way he owes everything to this
country and he
constantly says how he'll go to any ends
to protect her
once more you're defeated through
treachery except this time
you awaken in a dilapidated temple a
buddha sculptor
dragged you here from the field and he
nursed you back to health
he feigns this disinterest in you but he
betrays
a sincere knowledge and empathy of your
situation
he's being held prisoner in ashina
castle
they will soon make use of his bloodline
looking at you i'm sure you appreciate
the value it has
here too is the woman with the red
umbrella
that bid us to rise from the well my
name is emma
i am a doctor serving a certain master
what
master forgive me but for his safety
i cannot reveal his identity the master
she serves
is lord ishin who is again the now old
man who once brought the ashina to glory
and while it's true that ishin is allied
with his grandson ganichiro
he still directs his healer to assist
you in retrieving the prince
making no effort to cut you down even in
moments where he clearly could
the truth is ishin cares about the
ashina
insofar as his own skills can allow him
to save it
he cares about a good fight above all
else and
he will not abandon his own self his own
soul in pursuit of power for
using such a power as the dragon's
heritage comes at a great cost
dragon rot an epidemic that spreads to
those that you've been in contact with
stagnating their life force so that your
life force can thrive and this is a
story that has played out once before
long ago there was a dragon rod epidemic
in ashina once before
back then a cure was not achieved
every single person who caught it died
and in the time since your defeat to
gennichiro your divine air has been
wrestling with this burden of his power
we managed to drive them back once
but the interior ministry's army is far
too powerful
and that is why you wish to use the
power of my blood
it doesn't matter how much power you
obtain
you'll keep on fighting until you're a
monster
incapable of feeling pain or fear i do
not wish to corrupt the lives of men
look at this mountain of bodies ashina
cannot be defended by normal needs
not anymore
i could never be as strong as you
lord kenichiro i do not yet know
what it is i should do as you follow
kudos remnants
leading towards ashuna castle you
realize just how
beaten and bruised the ashina are as the
interior ministry steadily wears them
down
as ishiin falls to his illness and with
kuro refusing to grant the ashina the
power of his blood
something had to be done instead a tarot
troupe of physically enhanced
but vacant brutes are forced into battle
not to mention a bull fitted with a
blazing totem
troops and generals patrol the landscape
endlessly and
you cut them all down in kuro's name in
no small way
you single-handedly make it very easy
for the ashana to be invaded as it
stands
the wave of interior ministry troops are
breaking
upon one
[Applause]
[Music]
a retainer to lord ganichiro but he was
not always allied with the ashina
in fact he was once an infamous bandit
chief within these lands
but then asian defeated him and he was
so impressed by his strength
that he awarded him the spear of general
tamura
who you saw before and convinced gyobu
to fight for the ashina
instead with his death you destroy the
last real defense leading to ashina
castle
that is except for an old man within the
adjacent watchtower
a man with a talent for killing rats and
he's one who knows much about
the action of sword arts care to hunt
some rats with me
what rats have snuck into arshina
scurrying about like they own the place
and they must be cut down every last one
of them
war is on the horizon a dreadful one at
that
it will give birth to a demon
i'm certain of it the dead will rise as
mountains and the heat
will flow like an inferno but it is all
to get your prince back
and despite the endless entreaties of
gennichiro
and the suffering of the ashina at every
turn
kudo never once lost faith that you
would return he will risk his life
to take me home
for he is my shinobi
my lord i have come for you
this
will only take a moment
let's see
for as long as you are alive
the dragon's blood can never be mine
guenichiro is the best kind of villain
he's the sort that
commits evil in pursuit of a
single-minded purpose
not unlike you really you who spread
dragon rot
to keep your prince safe you who murder
hundreds of ashina soldiers
simply fighting for their land genichiro
truly believes
ashina cannot be saved through normal
means
and he risks everything by antagonizing
you
clinging to this faint hope of being
granted
kudos power impressive phenomena of the
divine air
but you deserve better would you not
answer to a different lord
heresy
heresy you say
if it is for the sake of preserving
hashina
i will seize any manner of heretical
strength
i will endure any burden
behold the lightning of tone away
lady tomoe was genichiro's mentor
she was a master of the sword who
descended to ashina
bearing many heretical arts and often
genichiro could be spotted in the
courtyard behind the castle
practicing his swordplay all the while
glaring
at the lightning roiling in the clouds
tomawe is an immensely important
character who
i actually fully expect to have her own
dlc but we'll touch on her
and what we know about her in the next
video
is this the rejuvenating waters
oh shina this slam
is everything to me
for her sake
i will shed humanity itself
resurrection
yes indeed
note that both ishin and kenichiro never
say they fight for ashina's people
no they fight for ashina's land one
small part
of ashina is exceedingly old after all
and
the ancient soil rocks and water are
said to have attracted
the attention of the gods add to this
the fact that the dragon's heritage was
set free
from its homeland and drifted here to
japan and we realized that there is
certainly an ancient origin
story here somewhere that we are missing
it's something that genichiro and ishin
likely know for they are unwilling to
accept
anything other than total ownership both
of the land and the water that runs
through it
to think that lord kenichiro would go as
far
as to drink the rejuvenating sediment
rejuvenating sediment
that's what we call a particularly
concentrated part
of the rejuvenating waters i'm sure you
saw it for yourself
the rejuvenating waters they flow from
the divine realm
all the way through ashina's lands but
it seems like they weren't meant for
this land
drink them and you may inherit an echo
of kudos immortality
at the risk of your own humanity the
rejuvenating sediment
grants great resilience in one's flesh
one becomes able to withstand blows that
would be fatal to anyone
else my mentor dogen devoted much
research
to its uses but all of his works
documents medicines everything
were burned and destroyed i'm not sure
who
but i heard one of the senior
apprentices
was able to salvage some of it probably
dojun and deep below ushina castle in a
long abandoned dungeon
full of undying men one of emma's fellow
disciples
dojin researches the waters for the
glory of ashina
they let us in on many discoveries but
one is that
red eyes commonly manifest in those who
are unable to achieve their desires
and considering there are harasser
soldiers guiding both ends of the cave
and that the results of these
experiments fight
for the ashina it's pretty clear that
ganichiro was
invested in this research furthermore
according to the ministry dowsing powder
we learned that the interior ministry
feared ashina her eyes bloodshot with
the waters of rejuvenation
lady emma tell me what has caused the
state
of this man the rejuvenating waters that
is what it is called
are you telling me that this is ashina's
secret weapon
i am those who drink it cannot fully die
no they become unable to die
at all the rejuvenating water
it also it springs from the dragon's
blood
does it not yes lady emma
i do not believe the dragon's blood is
sacred
not at all it's no surprise then that
when we next meet with kudo
he no longer wishes to abandon ashina
instead he's grown he's taken on the
immense responsibility of his power
and now he aims to sever immortality no
matter the cost
in no small way it was probably the
desperation of gennichiro
that led him to this conclusion and you
can tell that he even harbors
some regrets about resurrecting you i
have come for you
my lord yes you did well to come here
let us go we must leave ashana wolf
my blood the blood of the dragon
causes men to become undying the same
goes for you
yes my lord i wished to save you
i'm sure that i would do the same thing
given another chance
however undying begets stagnation
the immortal oath the rejuvenating
waters
the dragon rot they all corrupt men
to the point that they no longer live as
men
i wish to sever the chains of stagnation
bred by the dragon's heritage
wolf will you help me achieve this aim
the only way to absolve that guilt of
resurrecting you
is to use you to relinquish his power
altogether
the quest for that goal is long and it's
complicated but it's super rewarding to
understand
and it's a story for the next video
honestly it's a story we're going to be
telling for months
as sekiro is definitely more complicated
than many people are giving it credit
for
and after that we'll dive into the
endings what circumstances lead
to those endings and where can the story
go after
those endings and finally in every from
software game there is law
that can only really be pieced together
through context and
the relationships between different
parts of the story this is the hidden
law
the stories that have yet to be told and
probably will be told in the dlc to come
and then it will be time for shadows cry
twice
deep dives into some of the best
characters that from software have ever
written
so subscribe and consider checking out
the patreon if you're interested in
becoming a deeper
member of this community there's so much
to cover in the months to come so
let's figure it all out together and
i'll see you next time
you